okay so most brand collabs and special
edition phones are pretty half-assed
they just are like just print my logo on
the back and pay me already but realme
has made a Coca-Cola edition of their
newest Flagship and they didn't have to
go this hard so first of all it comes in
these boxes which have about 20
different Coca-Cola logos all over them
but then you get to the phone itself and
they've turned it up basically to an 11.
they even copied the sheen of a fresh
cold Coca-Cola can but it keeps going
okay you boot up the phone the wallpaper
is Coca-Cola and every single one of the
icons of the pre-installed apps is a
customized Coca-Cola version of that
icon the charging animation is bubbling
Coca-Cola the preset ringtone and camera
shutter and sound effects are Coca-Cola
Chimes and soda fizzing noises you you
didn't have to go this hard it also
comes with about 30 Coke stickers but
probably the craziest thing is it comes
with this SIM card ejector tool a tiny
bottle cap and a small statue of the
real me mascot that looks like it's made
of coke look I'd never buy it but I
gotta respect it